hey guys i am just mcdonald here at e3
with lindsay shirt up and you want a
really big competition you started in
sydney and now you're here in la at e3
and you just went to the u-visa press
conference yeah yeah unreal it's a dream
come true yeah so what it will be like
the big games I mean wizard old stuff
you're expecting was there anything that
they pulled out that you totally didn't
think was gonna happen well they start
off with that Assassin's Creed I really
love that I do a smash Black Flag so
really exciting seeing that but what
really got me going was am the division
that looked really cool just the level
of detail and a story and some of that's
really cool I mean I guess the thing
with the division is really doing
something different I mean like the map
layout the way it seems to have like
it's working with these different
technology stuff we've never seen in
games before I mean that's something
that you're glad to see you be soft kind
of experimenting with yeah I love seeing
your like a completely new direction
from Ubisoft just like seeing them
through some some of the similar games
but they finally branch out into like a
first person shooter it's really cool
I'm really excited and same as I'm
rainbow six that looks really cool super
excited about that too yeah I mean that
was a big surprise at the end they got
into it they showed us all the
multiplayer I mean do you think you'd be
like doing the job at the multiplayer I
mean with shooters across the board yeah
well bring in that whole our team aspect
the whole competitive gameplay mode into
it I really looking forward to that to
be cool to compete with friends
have really good crack at it so great
absolutely and what do you think of the
Far Cry trailer I mean that's what they
started off with that was a big intro to
the whole thing that was looking that
looked insane I I say to my friend when
when it first started I was like I don't
really know what game this is and then
it finally clicked and I saw some of the
main characters i was like this game
looks in unreal the graphics there to
just jaw-dropping yeah yeah that was a
totally wicked intro sorry what's it
like being at e3 like with the whole
experience it's like the whole
atmosphere of actually being in the city
where everything's going down yeah
what's really cool is I just walking
down the main streets and seeing all the
posters on all the buildings massive
Assassin's Creed banners and stuff I
that's just blows your mind you don't
actually see that when you're sitting at
home and behind your computer so that's
been really exciting just hanging out
here without something gamespot guys and
just enjoying it it's good that's great
ok so what's your number one time like
to have to pick your number one from UV
this year yeah I'd have to say that a
vision is that even better than its
ancestor yeah personally I I just it
blows me away I love the whole new story
direction and out there like a new clip
the depth of data on that in that game
is unreal sweet ok well thanks so much
for chatting to us and coming to the
city we will have more III coverage on
site so be sure to stay tuned for that
you